today i'd like to just tell a story
really
and that is about an itchy dishes the
youtube dishes that
students from all over the world come to
and they choose their
teacher and there's not many places in
the world that do full-time richie
dishes
a lot of the teachers that run dojos
have other jobs they don't have a
full-time
running dojo and i'm sure
as time goes by this is going to be less
and less
so apart from the japanese
masters there's some in america that
do dashes up and uh i had my period of
years of doing them when i had my dojo
in my
own garden it was really a beautiful
dojo
i loved it very much and i actually
regret
selling the house with the dojo in it we
used to have
seminars holding right about 35 40
students that was a good size had
kitchens
showers bubble beds
and over the years sometimes
there's zucchini dishes that stand out
or dashes that sand stand out
i should say and uh i'm just going to
mention no names but
some that make me smile and make me
think
a lot of the students they start off at
club they do their like you know they
they're inspired they want like i was
they want to do more they want to
explore
more about aikido they want to immerse
their self
i've had uh one fly all the way
he wasn't australian by he flew away
from australia
to the uk to be a rich dash with me
i picked him up from the railway station
we got back to the dojo he handed me a
credit card
it was a either a gold or a platinum
credit card and said take what you need
to teach me
and i said i don't take credit cards
this is a dojo it's not a
business but i said i do actually have a
business where
i could take it to my business in the
weekend
and i could take some money
i said let's let's see how it goes how
long do you want how long are you
thinking of staying
because they have to write first giving
you some idea what they want
how long they want to stay their
background
their teachers
and all his credentials added up to
being okay a reasonably new student in
the dojo
so this was on the friday afternoon
evening i picked him up
from the railway station took him back
to the dojo
walked him around and i gave him his
jobs to do he was only one up there at
the time and i said tomorrow there's a
weekend seminar
so you've come just right but we must
make sure the place is clean and tidy
first
i haven't missed anything because i said
i'm the one
that does it when there's no dashi here
so i was quite used to doing the same
work as
you would ask the students to do
he looked at me straight in the eyes and
said i don't
do a cleaning i'm just coming
for you to teach me
i had to quickly say to him
i don't know who you really are and i
don't know what you think that your
credit card
isn't going to pay for just teaching
you immerse yourself you do everything i
tell you
or you leave
so i wasn't annoyed at the time
sadly i think i would get annoyed but
obviously didn't show it
the next day comes he hadn't done
anything
and i was running around getting things
ready
thankfully some of my students came and
were very loyal students and they made
sure the place was
fit and ready by the saturday afternoon
it was festering because apart from the
training
he was doing nothing and the students
that came from
outside the dojo we're doing everything
so i asked one of my head students
please take the dash and show him what
he has to do
and make him help you he came back and
replied
he said he's not here to to do work
so after the uh
first day i went
to him and said pack all your things i'm
taking back to the
train station his answer was well
where will i go and i said well where
was you going
after the period you were here for
and at that time i had no idea whether
he was with me a week a month a year
because he said he wanted to see how it
would go
and i and i went along with that where
normally you don't do that
he said well i was going to italy i said
well there you go take your credit card
and
i didn't take any money and go
and my advice was never ever step on it
to tell me again because he was an
insult
to the whole program on a lighter note
i had a ration and a dutch
dashi two dashes come together
they started at the same time i would
teach them in the morning
and they would do their chores and then
they would have a program
that they had to train a minimum of one
hour a day
on the program i gave them
and being two of them it was really easy
for me to give the program because that
means they could do
a lot of techniques together rather than
just sword work
or who chemist singularly
after a few weeks the ration was
becoming
really superb his izukemi's forward
rolls
were beautiful and smooth and it was so
impressive
and the dutch dashi his roles were
terrible still and i couldn't work out
why he wasn't making any progress it was
as if
he was in a time warp of stillness
so i asked him um why he wasn't
improving i said you are
doing your training aren't you yes
sincere scentsy
so i thought perhaps it's because the
russian mind
works different than the european mind
so time went by
and the dutch boy would still not get
any better
and i asked the russian
um is there anything i should know
about the other dashi because he's not
improving
he looked at me and said no sense i
can't say anything
i thought this was rather strange and me
being working all day
and working for myself and my own
business i thought i would
just go back one afternoon
so one afternoon when they normally
trained man about
three o'clock i got there
a little bit earlier than that
and the russian student was already in
the dojo
doing his work doing his
program and i asked him where the
dutch student was and he says i don't
know scentsy
so i went off and found him in the bunk
bed fast asleep
and i confronted him and
every day straight after my teaching
program
in the morning seven to eight
he would go straight back to bed perhaps
have breakfast go straight back to bed
get up late in the day do the jobs then
there was lunch and then back to bed
so he wasn't training and it just goes
to show you know what you get out is
what you put in
the last one i'd like to talk about
today
was a from the uk he came from a club
and his parents dropped him off
and he come from the week and because he
was a young
boy in his mid teens
i said uh if you're only coming for a
week
let's see how you get on i didn't really
need any fees for that
and after a week he said that his
parents said he could stay for a month
so that's great so as the month was
going
by i thought well i'm gonna have to
approach him about
payment because with the nutrition
program there was a payment
and he said oh um because he was young
he would have to get a job
so i in the local area i saw a job for a
garden i said do you
think about gardening no
i'll teach you how to use a mower and
perhaps you can cut grass
do you have any clothes we can take you
to this interview
no it doesn't have any proper clothes
and the it's so funny because i lent him
my shoes that what were three times
bigger than
his feet a shirt that
would fit two of him a tie that i had to
do up because he didn't know how to do a
tyre
and he looked like something out of a
an odd movie
and of course he went for the job and
didn't get it surprise surprise
i found out afterwards his parents knew
nothing about this
and he told them that i asked him
to stay they didn't really know what to
do with him but
i found him a really nice little man
i have no idea if he's still trained i
could have after he left me
but when you give her
dashi things to do you sometimes forget
that you have to tell them every single
detail
a lot of students that go on dishes
anywhere in the world
are like children you're their father
you have to tell them exactly
detail by detail what to do and there
was a funny
time and i still smile today
i said james i want to put a sink in
the kitchen at the dojo
but we have to dig a soak away
and i need it to be one meter by one
meter
and i thought i went to work around
about
after my class about 8 30
and i had a busy day but managed to get
home
by six at night
and i thought i'll just go and see how
how he is i knew he said his name then
and i go walking down the path to the
dojo calling his day
and i nothing comes back
so i thought oh i'll see how he got on
with the
one meter by one meter soak away
and it was like a laurel and hardy film
or
one of these sketches where you
you see the film and you can't believe
it's so funny
i get to the hole and literally
a shovel full of dirt come flying by
out the hole and then another shovel of
dirt
so i looked in the hole and there he was
so far down that only the shovel was
reaching out
and i said what are you doing it
i said i wanted it a meter by a meter
he said sensei you didn't say how deep
you wanted
so he'd been working on it on and off
and they were only supposed to work for
now a day
he was working for on and off
and it was more than two meters deep
because i never told him
he got into trouble so many times from
the other
dashes when we had seminars
because he would sit in the it was a
summer house but we converted it into
the kitchen
and he would eat all their food and i
didn't know this until i heard
afterwards
and they would complain and when i said
why did you eat all their food
and he said well because i'm new today i
thought that anything that was put in
the fridge
or freezer was was for me i
thought they were bringing me bringing
me food
i didn't realize it was their lunch
so if you want to be an ichidashi
please think about exactly what being a
nutrition is
me as a teacher sees the funny side and
that's really great and i'm having a lot
of fun telling you
it may not be viewed as many times as
the other ones but
thank you for watching it and perhaps if
you enjoy
tell me you're enjoying it i have a lot
more stories that i can tell
thank you please leave your comments
likes and please subscribe